I were to like get really good grades
yes how much of an impact would that do
to Like My Success it really matters on
how you define success right so there's
a lot of ways to think about success the
world today thinks about success from
like a money
standpoint as far as money getting good
grades or bad grades has no correlation
to what you're going to do in money but
let me play this a little different to
you how much will that lead in your
success I would argue that success is
being happy and fulfilled and enjoy it
so by getting good grades you might go
to a great University where you might
meet your best friend who's amazing in
your dorm room and that person might
lead to enormous amounts of happiness
for you for your whole life and that's
real success so it depends on how you
analyze the question are you stressed
about getting good grades like cuz it
comes easy to you it comes easy
guy guy